(617) 830-4750 is the number. Let's go to
our color from the eight oh five area code.
Uh, I always forget is eight Oh five, uh,
Florida panhandle?
No.
Oh, that must be eight five zero. Yeah, that's
you.
Oh,
oh yeah. Did I interrupt you? I'm sorry.
Hello? Are Right. Calling eight oh five or
eight five Oh
oh eight oh five you're on right now. Eight
oh five, isn't it?
Five. Gotcha. It's actually Santa Barbara.
Oh, Santa Barbara. Okay. Beautiful. I was
there not long ago. I went to the, uh, Santa
Barbara courthouse. Beautiful building. Um,
and then I went out to a restaurant, like
at the tip of the pier, a seafood restaurant.
You know what I'm talking about?
Oh, yeah. The harbor. Yeah. The restaurant.
Fantastic. Crabcakes I highly recommend them.
Oh yeah, yeah. Excellent food there. Yup.
But a n u l I'm actually currently residing
in grass valley, Nevada county, California,
which is like a, well, Nevada county, uh,
borders on the state of Nevada.
You don't have this on speaker phone, do you?
Just to get that out of the way?
No, no. I'm on a hard wired, uh, t
so hard to believe.
Right. Okay. Can you hear me now? Yes. Okay,
great. David was so awesome, but I am actually
getting to talk to you, Andrew Jane 2020.
But anyhow, go. I concur with most all of
your views. I really like your work, but there's
one thing, uh, a bone, the pick that guy,
you just, um, it makes me question where you
stand because he seems so negative on the
left sometimes. It just so fatalistic, like,
you know, we don't have a chance or something.
Hey, it's really depressing to me sometimes.
Okay, let me deal with that. But now are you
exercising while you're on the phone?
No,
you're not. Okay. Are you doing on the couch?
You're sitting on it. Okay. Wow. Alright.
Listen, here's my thing. I don't think the
leftist destined to lose, I don't think the
left is destined to lose. My pessimism comes
from the last 15 years of being too meek and
weak on a bunch of different issues from not
taking the ground game of local politics seriously.
And I'm just calling it like I see, I get
people emailing me saying, David, you're depressed
now. It's not that I'm depressed, I'm just
telling you the way I see it.
Right, right. Well, I'm just, I'm using it
to inspire me more to just, you know, make
it happen. We, we gotta get, uh, all three
branches, 2020 buddy,
but all three, I mean, the White House, the
house and the Senate. Yeah. We're not getting
the Senate in 2020, but maybe in 2022. Listen,
I'm gonna let you go. I'm glad I've inspired
you, but your connection is crazy. I don't
know if you're, you're, uh, launching a, a
a rocket or something, but I'm gonna let you
go. Um, something going on there.